you guys see the garbage truck driving
around right you see the juice that's
dripping from the back that's the
magic don't say not the organization not
the Chuck D I tell you this story rest
his soul he was the coach of the magic
we went down there and worked out one
time and I did my thing against Bryce
drew that day and and their general
manager called my agent back and said
we'd like to bring Jason and Bryce back
in we didn't know who was more athletic
well that l a fire under my ass how
could they not know it's night night and
day told let's set that up before the
workout starts I'll go with Chuck D says
come here he says look I know who's more
athletic I know who's more talented they
want to do this we're going to play
one-on-one right from the get-go I I got
a tea time in in an hour let's have this
thing over in about 20 minutes I said
yes sir how long how long Bryce
Drew got a better chance pissing in a
hot sauce
bottle telling you